public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la ministre des solidarités et de la
santé est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité
agnès buzyn bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
grossir et merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de public sénat
avec radio classique avec les échos et
avec l afp est représenté ce soir par
mes deux confrères ici présents pour la
bria et jean francis pécresse
bonsoir monsieur madame la ministre
trois grandes questions pour vous ce
soir un peu ton soigner mieux en
dépensant moins
pari impossible pour le personnel comme
les responsables des hôpitaux à qui vous
répondre et de comment renforcer la
prévention en matière de santé les
pistes sont multiples ce sujet enfin
trois remboursement à 100% des lunettes
des prothèses dentaires et auditives
est ce une promesse intenable d'
emmanuel macron vous nous le dire et
tout à l'heure c'est parti avec la
première question donc sur un système
arrivé à bout selon vous une question
que va vous posez donc jean francis
pécresse
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours le premier
ministre edward fini par annoncer une
nouvelle baisse des tarifs payés aux
hôpitaux
est ce qu'on peut améliorer la situation
de l'hôpital et celle des malades aussi
est-ce qu'on peut soigner mieux en
dépensant moins
[Musique]
le constat est clair nous sommes je
pense arriver au bout d'un système un
système qui valorise énormément là les
actes quelle que soit leur pertinence
quelles que soient leurs intérêts le
caractère opportun de les faire et nous
avons décidé parce que nous avons
observé comme tous les acteurs du
système de santé s'accordent à le dire
que nous avons un système globalement
trop cloisonnée entre la ville hôpital
le médico social
nous avons un système qui valorise les
actes au détriment de la qualité de la
pertinence des actes que nous avons un
des parcours complexe pour les malades
d'autant plus complexe que les malades
sont de plus en plus âgées avec des
pathologies chroniques multiples et que
nous avons besoin de les orienter mieux
dans les parcours et donc nous avons
proposé une transformation globale du
système de santé qui se veut cohérente
et qui vise à répondre à ces trois
enjeux et mais ce que vous répondez à la
question soigner mieux en dépensant
moins est possible l'objectif c'est
justement une régulation par la qualité
et pas une régulation par la quantité et
c'est ce que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre
alors évidemment aujourd'hui les
hôpitaux qui ne sont arrivés qu'à
l'activité si on leur baisse les tarifs
ils vont souffrir mais l'objectif c'est
de diminuer la part de tarification à
l'activité d'augmenter la part sur la
valeur ajoutée de l'hôpital voulait dire
la qualité des prises en charge le
caractère humain va se faire tout de
suite sinon ça va se faire dans les mois
qui viennent attendant que votre réforme
delà de la tarification entre en oeuvre
ce que la sécurité sociale va verser aux
hôpitaux va encore baisser à des
hôpitaux qui dont le déficit a atteint
un milliard et demi d'euros en 2017
est-ce que vous n'allez pas accroître
leurs difficultés budgétaires
alors aujourd'hui le déficit n'est pas
tout à fait d'un milliard cinq il est
plutôt un peu au dessus d'un milliard
vous avez raison
l'objectif c'est alors on ne diminue pas
la somme donnée aux hôpitaux où on
augmente la part allouée aux hôpitaux
d'un milliard 7 par rapport à l'année
dernière mais c'est moins important que
ne le voudrait la trajectoire normale
des dépenses hospitalières
donc c'est une diminution de
l'augmentation je sais que c'est
toujours un concept un peu compliqué
pour la sécurité sociale mais c'est la
réalité
donc il ya quand même un milliard sept
de plus je pense qu'il a des
restructurations évidente à faire
notamment au sein des groupements
hospitalier de territoire où beaucoup
d'activités peuvent être redondantes ou
on peut quand même rationaliser je ne
dis pas que c'est la seule façon d'y
arriver
je pense qu'il faut une réforme de fond
et nous allons la mener alors dire et
structuration il y en a déjà eu et des
efforts de fait et ils sont toxiques et
aussi été réalisés par certains
établissements je vous propose d'écouter
l'un des responsables des fédérations
élections puisqu'ils sont quatre
vous l'avez lu dans le journal du
dimanche qui hier avoir dénoncé donc des
mesures comptables aveugle ne distille
en écoute donc antoine dubout qui craint
des dépôts de bilan madame le ministre
je représente ici vous savez le secteur
privé non lucratif dans le domaine de la
santé qui vous est interpellé qui vous
interpellent car il était extrêmement
inquiet sur l'évolution des
tarifications hospitalier
celles ci ont baissé en cinq ans de
l'ordre de 9%
nous avons interpellé avec nos collègues
des autres fédérations pour vous
demander ce que vous pourriez faire pour
nous assurer que nous pourrions
continuer à offrir le service public à
nos concitoyens que lui répondez vous
parce que l'on ressent aussi là une
forme de souffrance évidemment avec
l'impossibilité est expliquée de ne plus
poursuivre l'émission d'abord antoine
dubout sort de mon bureau
pas le temps donc on aime cette
conversation je pense qu'il est
parfaitement en phase avec la réforme de
transformation que nous proposons
aujourd'hui il comprend que c'est la
seule façon aujourd'hui de sauver les
établissements de santé les hôpitaux
c'est d'entrer d'aller vers une réforme
globale de notre système de santé de
façon à mieux articuler la ville et à
l'hôpital à tarifs et les parcours de
soins à diminuer la part de tarification
à l'activité tout le monde en est
persuadé
le problème c'est ce décalage de temps
entre ce que vivent les hôpitaux
aujourd'hui le fait que la réforme ne
pourra se mettre en oeuvre qu'en 2019 il
faut que nous tenions encore un an
on arrive très tard dans un système qui
a dérivé et qui est arrivé au bout le
temps d'en faire le constat est de
proposer une transformation de fond
cette année va être compliqué hall aubry
est ce que la solution ça passe
également par un rapprochement entre les
hôpitaux et la médecine de ville qui va
falloir qu'il est un gars aussi réguler
cette médecine de ville qu'est ce que
quelles sont les pistes sur lesquelles
vous pouvez travailler et bien c'est ce
que nous proposons qui est d'aller vers
une tarification à la qualité et au
parcours de soins y compris en médecine
de ville c'est à dire que nous ne
souhaitons pas continuer à financer la
totalité des actes en ville via une
tarification à l'acte donc là y voit
survie des tours de vis aussi pour la
médecine de ville
cc c'est quelque part ce que nous devons
français c'est-à-dire de tarifs et des
bons parcours de soins aujourd'hui nous
tarifs font des actes quelle que soit
leur intérêt pour le malade et donc nous
voulons arriver ce qui est pertinent ce
qui est utile aux malades et ce qui est
de qualité y compris en médecine de
ville
ça va être donc des tarifications pas au
parcours où les professionnels de ville
ou de l'hôpital vont avoir chacun une
part de de cette première c'est ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire c'est
que le paiement à l'acte chez le médecin
généraliste chez le médecin de ville va
être appelée à disparaître n'ont
certainement pas c'est quelque chose
auquel r maintenant pas du tout les
médecins de ville sont très attachés au
payement là et il est évident que
paiement à l'acte est utile pour toutes
les consultations aiguë quand vous avez
la grippe quand vous avez un une demande
particulière mais chez quelqu'un qui a
un diabète par exemple connu qui va
vivre avec son diabète 20 ans dont on
sait que chaque année il doit avoir x
consultation x examens de sang une
consultation chez un podologue chez un
cardiologue chez un ophtalmo on peut
imaginer tarifs et donc là un parcours
sur les par exemple sur les maladies
chroniques sur la maladie chronique
oui une part de forfait quoi pour comme
l'apl chaque fois devant halak pour
éviter duré plus de paiement à l'acte
sur les maladies chroniques en vie alors
nous allons nous allons mener des
expérimentations dans le cadre de
l'article 51 de la loi de financement de
la sécurité
avec des financements parcours
expérimentaux sur les maladies
chroniques nous avons prévu de commencer
sur les a élevés et il est évidemment
pas question de revenir complètement sur
le paiement à l'acte nous savons à quel
point les médecins sont attachés aussi
au fait nommer les maladies chroniques
on comprend voilà on nous pensons que
pour un certain nombre de maladies
cela permettrait d'harmoniser les prises
en charge quand on sait qu'il ya des
référentiels de prise en charge ça
éviterait des disparités de pratique
parce qu'on voit que d'un territoire à
l'autre quand on a quatre fois plus de
césariennes dans une région que dans une
autre
trois fois plus de retrait des amygdales
dans une région au cours d'une autre on
se rend bien compte que ces disparités
de pratique elle cache quelque part des
inégalités d'accès aux soins et
peut-être des mauvaises pratiques on
n'est pas créé une tempête là chez les
médecins généralistes s'estiment pas
assez payés à la hauteur de leur
consultation la plupart du temps mais
peut-être faut-il payer autrement que
simplement valorisant le sais moi je
trouve que c'est assez humiliant pour
les médecins et notamment les médecins
généralistes de devoir se battre tous
les deux trois ans pour essayer d'avoir
une revalorisation de leurs
consultations autant repenser un système
avec eux plus vertueux
évidemment ces réformes ne se feront pas
sans les médecins pour moi c'est à eux
de déterminer ce qui est un parcours de
qualité pour un malade ce n'est pas à
l'administration de choisir comment
soigner un diabétique
c'est clairement un pain un enjeu
médical que des définir le bon parcours
et de trouver la tarification qui
correspond à la valeur à la valeur de
test on aura enfin ce fameux dossier
médical personnalisé numériques
accessibles par tous par nous par notre
médecin de ville par l'hôpital par une
profusion de santé alors le dossier
médical partagé il est enfin
opérationnel il ya aujourd'hui plus d'un
million de dossiers ouverts dans des
régions expérimental il pourrait être
totalement déployés d'ici la fin de
l'année 2018 par l'assurance maladie
et ça ce sera une source d'économie on
sera suivi par wii ah oui parce que
aujourd'hui quand on parle de pertinence
des actes beaucoup d'actes sont refaits
entre la ville et l'hôpital tout
simplement parce que le médecin de ville
ne récupère pas la radio locale avait
déjà livré de santé sa chou et la
je pense qu'il faut maintenant un outil
numérique à 10 ans d'âge et on aura tous
notre dossier m oui c'est le jeu sur
amélie aujourd'hui le site de
l'assurance maladie
on peut ouvrir soit même son dossier
médical ou le médecin qui doit y rentrer
des données de santé serait cependant
une autre interpellation pour vous
madame la ministre c'est christophe
prudhomme médecin urgentiste que vous
connaissez bien qui représente la cgt
n'est qu'ils s'adressent directement à
vous madame busin ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui c'est l'arrêt des fermetures
de lits l'arrêt des fermetures de
services d'urgence en particulier les
petits services d'urgence comme c'est le
cas à l'heure actuelle en bourgogne la
fermeture des samu et surtout nous avons
besoin de personnel de personnel dans
les ehpad pour que les patients ne
viennent pas aux urgences où il stagne
sur des brancards pendant des heures
parce qu'il manque d'infirmières et de
médecins pour pouvoir les maintenir dans
ces ehpad dans ces maisons de retraite
alors madame busin deux questions est-ce
que vous êtes prête aujourd'hui à nous
recevoir pour discuter dans le cadre
d'un moratoire sur les fermetures de
lits et sur les plans d'économie d'autre
solution que celle que vous proposez et
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui à la hauteur
de la colère des personnels soignants
alors interpellations et puis demande
d'un moratoire sur les fermetures de
lille ces deux questions assez
différentes
d'abord j'ai reçu la cgt vendredi
dernier donc j'ai reçu les représentants
de la cgt
la semaine dernière pour parler c'était
la cgt-santé donc c'était vraiment ce ce
domaine dont nous avons discuté
aujourd'hui des difficultés aujourd'hui
rencontrer dans les ehpad il me pose une
question sur les hospitalisations
inutiles aux urgences des personnes
d'âgés nous avons parce que nous sommes
d'accord avec ce constat qu'il ya trop
de personnes qui ont envoyé aux urgences
des ehpad faute d'infirmières de nuit
faute de médecins donc nous avons créée
dans la loi de santé
nous avons ajouté 100 millions d'euros à
la tarification des ehpad 100 millions
d'euros dédiés à créer des postes
d'infirmiers et d'aides-soignants dans
les ehpad et 10
d'euros supplémentaires uniquement pour
des postes d'infirmières de nuit pour
éviter des hospitalisations
enfin nous avons mis de côté un budget
dédié à l'équipement en télémédecine des
ehpad de façon à ce que ces infirmières
de nuit ne soient pas isolés face à des
difficultés et puissent par télémédecine
prendre la tâche d'un service et
pourtant une nouvelle mobilisation est
annoncée le 15 mars
c'est normal juste pour revenir c'est
normal ça a été voté fin décembre
il est normal qu'on les ait pas
d'aujourd'hui ça n'est plus normal vous
nous dites que le case normal ça n'est
plus normal de se mobiliser alors non ce
que je veux qu'on en fait je comprends
que entre un vote d'un budget au plfss
en décembre et ce que ressentent les
gens dans les ehpad aujourd'hui il ya un
délai de mise en place de ces mesures il
faut recruter des personnels il faut que
ce soit évidemment à la main des
directeurs d'ehpad et ça prend un
certain temps c'est tout ce que je dis
localisation à laquelle même s'associent
des associations de retraités ce qui
n'est pas courant pour pour le coup on a
vu des choses terribles ce qui se passe
dans les ehpad et peut-être sur des
ehpad quand même un peu
d'éclaircissement aujourd'hui lisez pas
de sont financés par trois voix
concomitante
l'état finance les soins c'est-à-dire
infirmières aides soignantes les
départements financent la dépendance est
là aujourd'hui qui pose le plus de
problème c'est la prise en charge de la
dépendance
l'aide à manger habiller les gens les
sortir du lit aujourd'hui c'est la
partie dépendance qui pose problème est
en fait il ya une troisième partie
financé par les personnes ou leur
famille qu'est la partie hébergement sur
la dépendance nous devons ouvrir un vrai
grand débat de société qui et comment
nous allons prendre en charge la
dépendance dans l'avenir mais sur la
partie soit l'état fait un effort
considérable cette année à la loi nous
dit que vous avez déjà donc déjà répondu
à la mobilisation du 15 mars 1 c'est ça
les réponses à n'auront pas la partie
dépendance qui ne dépend pas de l'étang
oui ah d'accord
justement si c'est une question de la
prise en charge de ce risque de
dépendance avait sous le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy il avait été question de
créer un cinquième risque de la sécurité
sociale et puis cette idée elle a été
abandonnée sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande est ce que vous êtes
favorable à ça ou est-ce que vous vous
seriez plutôt en faveur d'une assurance
privée obligatoire par exemple
aujourd'hui évidemment je ne vais pas
donner une solution je pense que c'est
ça mérite un débat de société
ça mérite un débat ouvert et donc nous
nous sommes en train de réfléchir à une
feuille de route pour ouvrir une
concertation d'ici fin mars
l'idée d'annoncer d'ici fin mars une
concertation sur les enjeux de la
dépendance parce que cela mérite un
débat en profondeur à la fois avec les
personnels les personnes qui s'occupent
des personnes âgées dépendantes mais
également les élus les citoyens et je
crois que c'est trop tôt aujourd'hui
pour donner une solution unique
vous êtes engagés sur des chantiers au
long cours vous avez dit comme votre
collègue blanc kerboulé reste ministre
de la santé cinq ans je ne sais pas le
premier décideront mais ce sont des
projets de long terme ça c'est sûr nous
avons réalisé avec opinionway
un sondage et nous avons posé cette
question aux français pensez vous
possible d'améliorer la qualité des
soins à l'hôpital sans augmenter le
budget est bien c'est peut-être contre
intuitif mais 50 pour cinquante deux
pour cent des français ont répondu oui
alors c'est peut-être un encouragement
ou est une surprise pour vous les deux
non je pense que les français quand on
passe à l'hôpital on sait qu'il ya aussi
des problèmes d'organisation dans
l'hôpital il n'y a pas que des problèmes
de financement même s'il peut y en avoir
évidemment il y a aussi une
rationalisation des pratiques des
filières de prise en charge et je pense
que les français sont conscients qu'on
peut peut-être faire un peu mieux
deuxième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
avec la deuxième question que va vous
poser
paulo bria voilà comment renforcer la
prévention en matière de santé les
pistes sont multiples on a parlé du
tabac de l'alcool des vaccins ou de la
noyade ou de la nourriture industrielle
pardon ces derniers jours alors parmi
toutes toute cette énumération
allez-vous des priorités en ce qui
concerne tous les politiques de
prévention tout tout
on peut comme ça de ne pas prioriser
surtout pas moi je pense que la
prévention à tous les âges de la vie
dans tous les milieux et quel que soit
l'enjeu c'est vraiment un pari que nous
faisons sur l'avenir de façon à réduire
les dépenses de santé parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui pourquoi nous dépensons
autant c'est que nous sommes très bons
sur les soins très mauvais sur la
prévention et que nous vieillissons
certes nous vieillissons loin ces
derniers nous mourrons pas mes freins en
bonne santé
les français ont une durée de vie longue
mais pas en bonne santé donc mon enjeu
c'est de faire en sorte que nous vivions
longtemps et en bonne santé donc nous
allons ouvrir toutes les pistes de la
prévention et je travaille avec tous mes
collègues ministres aujourd'hui un grand
programme national de prévention dans
tous les milieux
sur tous les secteurs alors je pose la
question différemment quel est le lobby
le plus coriace au w
dobbin d'abord les lobbies ne font pas
très peur ils sont partout oui oui on
part tous évidemment quand on
travaillait dans le champ de
l'environnement nous savons très bien
qu'il ya des lobbys dans le champ de des
comportements il ya d'autres lobbys dans
les vaccins sont encore d'autres lobbys
qui s'expriment pas forcément des
l'habit des lobbys industriels ni
dorothée les opposants là où laura on en
parlera là on va parler par exemple du
vin rouge et qu'on vous dit les lobbies
ont partout peut-être que vous pensez à
certaines chambres parlementaires
je ne sais pas on va écouter en tous les
cas une interpellation d'une sénatrice
rds ce qui est viticultrice également
mme nathalie delattre qui l'autre jour à
interpeller directement le premier
ministre mais c'est vous qui étiez visé
en lait coûte votre ministre de la santé
ne cesse de jeter l'opprobre sur notre
tête sa stratégie nationale de santé
soit de passer d'une politique de
prévention des risques à une politique
de prévention de toute consommation
d'alcool mais la consommation de vin a
déjà été divisée par deux en 50 ans sans
régler pour autant le problème de
l'alcoolisme
cette voie n'est donc pas la bonne alors
monsieur le premier ministre
ma question est simple allez vous
reconnaître l'existence d'une
consommation responsable
vous souhaitez vous suivre votre
ministre de la santé qui veut faire de
la france le pays de la prohibition
alors il n'a pas dénoncé le vin c'est un
peu outrancier comme propos jamais pas
les provisions moi même j'aime beaucoup
boire un verre de vin c'est un
patrimoine français je le reconnais
après mons ce que j'ai dit la seule
chose que j'ai dite d'ailleurs je n'ai
jamais parlé de l'alcool c'est
intéressant je n'ai jamais parlé de
l'alcool avant l'émission de france 2
sur l'alcoolisme qui s'est déroulé il y
a dix jours je n'ai jamais prononcé le
mot alcool depuis que je suis arrivé au
ministère et on me fait dire que je veux
la prohibition que je déteste les
viticulteurs donc il ya des propos
outranciers qui vise à décrédibiliser ma
parole je pense qu'il ya un sujet alcool
dans notre pays qui
notamment pour les populations
vulnérables je pense aux jeunes avec le
binge drinking on a vraiment des efforts
à faire il ya des jeunes qui meurent
aujourd'hui de comme alcoolique sans
parler des accidents évidemment de la
route
nous avons un problème des femmes
enceintes ou les messages sont
insuffisamment porté sur le fait qu'il
faut boire zéro alcool pendant la
grossesse et ça c'est vraiment un
message de santé publique
après c'est de l'information pour moi
l'information que je dois aux français
que simplement que dans le vin il a une
bolée kull d'alcool par exemple que le
monde doit boire avec modération que
plus on boit d'alcool puis c'est
dangereux mois on en boit mieux c'est
voilà c c'est un message de santé riquet
le vin le vin modèle est qu'il peut être
sans danger et finalement c'est ça la
question
scientifiquement ce n'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne c'est proportionnel
voilà donc ensuite on veut me faire dire
que sous prétexte que je dis des vérités
scientifiques
je voudrais une prohibit rice loin de
moi cette envie là ça n'est pas le sujet
je veux faire de l'information
moi je pense que en tant en matière de
prévention
chacun doit connaître les risques qu'il
prend pour sa santé et ensuite chacun
est libre mais quand quelqu'un
souhaitent rouler deux sens sur
l'autoroute sans sa ceinture il prend à
dire qu'il le connaît alors il prend les
points juste pour les autres aussi aussi
mais au moins vous savez sur l'alcool
c'est vrai aussi pour les autres
questions parce que l'alcool ça entraîne
des violentes les violences conjugales
de la violence routière parce que ça ça
a un coût pour la société qui est
considérable il est calculé par la cour
des comptes à 120 milliards d'euros tout
compris en termes de pertes de vies de
pertes de production de richesse un coût
pour la sécurité sociale en elle même de
plusieurs milliards d'euros
donc voilà c'est s'est il ne faut pas
penser que l'alcool est juste un
problème personnel c'est aussi un
problème sociétal et questions simples
sur le vin justement et sur l'alcool
général puisque vous parliez des femmes
enceintes vous savez il ya un projet
dont on parle qui est qui consista en
fait multiplier par deux la taille du
petit logo femme à femme enceinte qui
est apposé sur les étiquettes de
bouteilles de vin
est ce que vous confirmez ce projet télé
est ce qu'on va passer de 0 5 cm à 1 cm
alors si les prix comme une mesure assez
discriminatoire par les producteurs de
vin aujourd'hui c'est une bataille qui
visiblement assez ancienne que j'ai
découvert en arrivant au ministère qui
est la bataille de la direction générale
de la santé pour faire en sorte que les
fans en somme voit le logo est ce qu'en
fait aujourd'hui
si vous interrogez les fans en salle sur
la consommation d'alcool elles ne savent
pas que l'alcool est interdit pendant la
grossesse elles ne le savent pas donc
c'est ça l'enjeu est est ce que le logo
doit faire un centimètre pour être vu ou
0 7 cm je n'en sais rien en tous les cas
la discussion est en cours sur la taille
du logo et sur ce logo femmes femmes
enceintes encore une fois il ya un
projet de votre ministère qui consiste à
mettre ce logo femmes enceintes sur des
médicaments et l'académie de médecine
s'offusque contre ce projet parce
qu'elle dit que ce sera contre productif
et des femmes enceintes qu'ils devraient
prendre des médicaments en fait vont
vont pas en prendre
comme elle d'autres comme elles
devraient le faire est ce que vous
confirmez quand même votre intention de
le faire alors de toute façon ça a déjà
commencé à le logo femmes enceintes sur
des médicaments
c'est ça a été voulue à la suite de la
sphère de la dgde paquin ou en fait les
femmes prenaient le médicament le
médecin le prescrivait et elle n'était
pas au courant de la dangerosité donc il
y a eu la volonté d'être plus informatif
et de donner l'information aux femmes
enceintes qu'un médicament est
potentiellement toxiques mais bien
entendu il faut qu'en regard de cette
mesure qui fait prendre des risques
d'arrêt d'un médicament
il y ait de l'information médicale qui
disent aux femmes oui vous êtes enceinte
mais moi votre médecin je continue de
vous le prescrire vous demande de ne pas
arrêter c'est une balance bénéfices
risques est ce qu'il vaut mieux les
laisser dans l'ignorance ou leur
permettre d'être informés mais quand en
parallèle le médecin explique pourquoi
il poursuit la prescription par la suite
rôle ou non mais non bien sûr ma vie est
tellement de prévention à entreprendre
alors nous allons parler des aliments
ultra transformer ce sont les nuggets ce
que par industriels et soupe en poudre
que les sodas et les sodas évidemment
ces derniers jours une étude est sorti
qui mettaient en garde contre les
dangers de ces aliments
ce serait éventuellement cancérogènes
comment agir face à ces risques
alors vous savez que nous avons mis en
place au ministère ce qu'on appelle le
nutrisse corps qui est un score qui
informe sur la valeur nutritive des
aliments notamment des aliments
transformés aujourd'hui la charte a été
signée par plus de 30 industrielles ça
représente quasiment 15% des produits
alimentaires aujourd'hui qui affiche du
tri score il a vocation à s'étendre
ces remarques et comme une vraie avancée
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
par le commissaire européen à la santé
avec une volonté de l'étendre et ctu un
score qui est très bien compris par les
gens et quand on le suit et qu'on achète
en fonction de la valeur nutritive et de
la qualité des animaux et bien on s'est
rendu compte que ça n'augmente pas le
coût du panier pour les moules à
ménagères entre guillemets qui fait ses
courses
sas a une valeur éducative ça n'est pas
discriminant pour les populations les
plus vulnérables et qui ont moins
d'argent et l'idée c'est de poursuivre
cette mesure d'information qui permet de
limiter effectivement des aliments trop
gras trop salé trop sucré qui nuisent
effectivement à la santé c'est une très
belle était trop transformé ça veut dire
qu'il faut inciter à manger des produits
davantage brut
oui il faut inciter on le sait on le
sait de longue date cette étude est
particulière parce qu'elle fait vraiment
le lien entre cancer et aliments
transformés ça c'est la première fois
qu'on a cette information et ça doit
nous inciter à manger des produits bruts
que nous cuisinons nous mêmes
les français savent faire ça assez bien
alors il vient également également bien
sûr là les vaccins dans le cadre de la
politique de prévention avec un rappel
tragique il y a quelques jours cette
femme qui est morte aux jeunes est ce
que vous êtes satisfaite de l'entrée en
vigueur au 1er janvier je sais pas si
vous avez déjà des informations
deux des onze vaccins obligatoires
désormais pour les enfants alors
satisfaite
quelque part du chèque que tout ce débat
de l'année dernière a permis une
meilleure information des français et
les pédiatres me disent que maintenant
lorsqu'ils proposent un vaccin même
avant l'obligation officielle au 1er
janvier ils se sentaient plus écoutée
par leur patientèle arriver mieux à
défendre l'idée de la vaccination
parce que les gens se sont approprié le
sujet
nous avons réussi à lutter contre un tas
de fake news de fausses informations sur
internet
nous avons osé dire que c'était une
mesure importante de santé publique
malheureusement l'histoire la réalité
notre pays nous rattrape avec ce cas
dramatiques une épidémie de rougeole qui
n'est pas finie aujourd'hui dans trois
régions
c'est un truc rappel à la raison par
appel à la raison on est un pays qui à
oublier évidemment les grandes épidémies
et lorsque la couverture vaccinale
baisse comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
aquitaine
elle est bien on voit la réémergence
d'épidémie et la rougeole c'est mortel
un cas sur trois mille alors c'était le
sujet de la deuxième question de notre
sondage opinionway les onze vaccins
obligatoires
êtes vous favorable bien oui à 55% mais
il ya quand même 44% des français qui
sont opposés donc il y a quand même une
défiance qui demeure diriez vous que
c'est une forme d'obscurantisme à
combattre non moins la défiance je la
comprends beaucoup de choses circulent
les français ont encore besoin d'être
mieux informés il faut que les médecins
et des documents qui leur permettent
d'accompagner leurs patients face aux
angoisses et inquiétudes que je
considère légitime
il faut donner des questions réponses
argumentées
moi je pense que ce sondage va aller en
s'améliorant si vous le refaire dans six
mois j'ai fait le pari oui je fais le
pari de l'information de la pédagogie
il n'ya pas quand même une forme de
spécificité française dans cette
défiance à l'égard des des vaccins et au
fond est ce que ça ne vient pas des
différents scandales qui ont pu mettre
en cause des laboratoires peut-être
pharmaceutique dans voilà est-ce qu'il
n'ya pas cette responsabilité là à la
base de cette défiance il ya
certainement tous les scandales
évidemment il ya eu aussi l'histoire du
vaccin contre l'hépatite b qui à un
moment à semer le trouble et avant qu'on
trouve qu'il n'y avait pas de toxicité
l'a fallu plusieurs années il y avait un
doute sur h1n1 au moment de cette
épidémie bref tout ça n'était pas
propice et puis par ailleurs il ya une
culture scientifique est insuffisant
les français aujourd'hui on voit bien
que le rationnel et la logique
scientifique effet scientifiques sont
opposés de façon équivalente à des
croyances des sentiments or les faits
scientifiques sont en effet scientifique
et c'est cela que je veux remettre dans
les mains des médecins dans leur
argumentaire parce que tout ne se vaut
pas un sentiment une opinion ne vaut pas
une étude scientifique publiée notamment
en termes de vaccination voit les
dernières questions sur ce thème oui
surtout jour sur les faits scientifiques
souhaitent à drap des études montrent
que les cigarettiers aurait menti
finalement sur le taux de goudron de
nicotine dans leur paquet de cigarettes
alors le comité national contre le
tabagisme arias envisager une plainte au
pénal
vous vous soutenez cette démarche contre
les cigarettiers c'est une association
je les laisse faire moi je n'ai pas moi
même mené une étude sur les taux de
goudron le ministère ne l'a pas fait
donc non mais c'est incroyable cette
étude parce que on croit fumer un paquet
de cigarettes est en fait on enfume deux
voire dix je ne suis pas fumeur mais
quand même où je pense à ceux qui fument
malheureusement oui alors il est clair
que si ça s'avère prouver ce qui est
probable il ya un vrai sujet
d'informations en encore et là il s'agit
d'un lobby extrêmement 600 m2 mensonge
puisque d'information le plus puissant
du prix oui cela dit entre eux en fumée
une heure fumée deux ou en fumée 3 très
sincèrement aujourd'hui nous savons
exactement que ce qui compte c'est la
durée du tabagisme est pas le nombre de
cigarettes fumées pour avoir pour le
cancer du poumon ce qui est le plus
important c'est d'arrêter de fumer c'est
la longueur du tabla la durée du
tabagisme et donc il ne suffit pas de
réduire sa consommation
il faut arrêter tout de questions sur la
formation des médecins est ce qu'on va
vers une libéralisation totale du
numerus clausus c'est à dire vers une
libération du nombre des étudiants en
médecine question numéro un sur ce sujet
deuxième question brève est ce que vous
êtes favorable à l'interdiction du
redoublement de la première année de
médecine
alors j'ai d'abord répondre à votre
deuxième question parce que c'est
simplement une expérimentation qui est
permise par la loi et donc ses revenus
ces deux universités qui étaient
submergées en fait par le nombre
d'étudiants ont voulu organiser une
première année de médecine sans
redoublement tout en augmentant ce
moment le numerus clausus pour les
primes ans de façon à ne pas créer une
inégalité de traitement site une
expérimentation nous verrons ce qu'elle
donne et encore je crois que l'une des
facultés a renoncé in fine et à la
mettre en place
ensuite la num le numerus clausus il ya
un vrai débat sur la façon dont on
sélectionne les prêts dès les étudiants
aujourd'hui il y a une vraie
désespérance de cette génération de bon
élève de terminale s qui se retrouve
bloquée par un concours très
discriminant mais il ne faut pas
utiliser le débat sur une meilleure
clausus pour penser que cela cela va
régler le problème des déserts médicaux
ça c'est une fausse information qu'on
donne aux français parce que le numerus
clausus sinon le libéralisme cela va
avoir un effet différé avec des
étudiants qui sortiront qui seront en
capacité de s'installer dans les
territoires en 2030 2035 et nous savons
qu'à cette période là la démographie
médicale aura de nouveau augmenté et que
nous ne serons plus en pénurie de
médecins que nous le sommes actuellement
donc moi je pense qu'il ya un sujet des
muscles aux us peut-être d'augmentation
du nombre un sujet recrutement des
compétences de médecins qu'est-ce que
nous comment nous souhaitons les
sélectionner nos médecins mais ne
mélangeons pas numerus clausus avec la
question des déserts médicaux c'est la
salle est d'accord la troisième partie à
refonder troisième question maintenant
c'est paulo où brilla qui vous la posez
tout de suite
[Musique]
le remboursement à 100% des lunettes des
prothèses dentaires des prothèses
auditives c'était une promesse d'
emmanuel macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle
est ce que c'est une promesse de nabeul
nouveaux fans nous faisons tout pour la
tenir aujourd'hui puisque vous le savez
les négociations sont officiellement
ouvertes dans les trois filières depuis
le 18 janvier
ça avait commencé un peu avant avec les
dentistes sur les prothèses dentaires et
donc les trois filières sont traités de
façon très différente parce qu'elle pose
des questions différentes de répartition
des marges
évidemment entre les différentes
professions impliquées l'objectif c'est
d'arriver à élaborer une feuille de
route de mise en place du reste à charge
0 dans ces trois filières pour le mois
de juin avec une annonce qui pourrait
être faite en juin de la façon dont ça
va se mettre en place
ça ne sera pas le même calendrier pour
le dentaire l'optique et les
audioprothésistes qui pourraient avait
en premier ok alors probablement les
annonces seront plus précoce dans le
champ dentaire puisque la négociation
conventionnelle est en train d'aboutir
avec les chirurgiens dentistes en ce
moment à la cnam les filières
d'audioprothèse et d'optique sont plus
complexes il ya plus d'intervenants et
donc il faut bien démembré ce que fait
chacun chaque étape et voir où nous
avons des marges de manoeuvre de toute
façon la promesse du président c'était
un reste à charge 0 dans les trois
secteurs pour 2022
et ça la promesse sera tenue la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est celle du
calendrier deux meilleurs de la question
qui se pose aussi c'est la nature de
ceux comme on dit le de pagnes et de
deuxième période
100% de quoi offrir qu'est-ce qu'on ne
parlera pas au fait
à quelle hauteur on a envie de dire
quand on va acheter une paire de
lunettes on sait combien ça coûte
vous allez nous rembourser
à hauteur de combien alors ce que nous
avons voulu c'est définir ce qui est un
panier de soins utiles nécessaires aux
français et de qualité et par exemple
quel type de verre vous accepté de
rembourser à 100%
est-ce que des verts qui fonce au soleil
sont nécessaires je ne suis pas sûr nous
n'en n'avons pas tout c'est autour de la
table par contre quand on est très bien
d'avoir des verts qu'il soit demain
c'est utile c'est certes esthétique mais
pas seulement
et donc ça ça doit être dans le panier
de soins pour la myopie ou bien alors le
maximum alors aujourd'hui nous
définissons pour chaque secteur ce qui
est un panier de soins de qualité est
nécessaire nous mettons d'accord avec
les professionnels du secteur mais aussi
avec les associations de patients et
d'usagers sur ce qui est nécessaire et
ce que nous ne voulons pas évidemment
payer c'est ce qui est superflu ce qui
fait ce qui fait l'objet d'un choix
individuel
enfin choix de confort l'amour je vais
être plus fort ou un choix de montures
extrêmement cher n'a pas vocation à être
remboursés pour tout le monde la même
façon par contre il faut quand même que
la qualité soit au rendez vous ça n'est
pas un panier de soins bas de gamme que
nous proposons d'accord mais vous pouvez
pas le chiffre est encore là c'est en
quoi c'est bien mais par exemple canton
se poser une prothèse dentaire on
choisit pas de solution confort la ja
sur les prothèses dentaires il est clair
que un panier de soins ça sera des
prothèses qui ne soient pas des dents en
or par exemple de partir de la céramique
donc c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est pas
du bas de gamme c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'esthétique de correct pour tout
le monde s contre c'est à 100%
est-ce qu'en contrepartie on ne risque
pas d'assister à une augmentation des
tarifs tout simplement
alors aujourd'hui une part de une part
du surcoût sera pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie nous le savons déjà
des négociations sont en cours avec les
mutuelles elles ont bien dans leurs
objectifs
la non augmentation des coûts nous
allons essayer de nous tenir à cet
objectif
et l'idée de voir comment nous pouvons
avoir des marges entre les différents
secteurs c'est en train d'être
travaillés mais les mutuelles d'ailleurs
dans leur livre blanc qu'elles nous ont
proposé pour aller vers le reste à
charge ayrault avait bien compris que la
promesse du président ça n'était pas une
augmentation des tarifs des milieux des
mutuelles sinon les français n'y gagnent
homme d'alors pour terminer sur ce sujet
au gré par les deux du coût pour la
sécurité sociale du budget de la sécu
quand est ce que ce sera le déficit zéro
est ce que là vous vous donnez un
objectif oui nous avons un objectif de
déficit zéro ok mais alors en 2000 2001
et nous allons réduire encore le déficit
de plus de trois milliards cette année
et donc nous arrivons bientôt au déficit
zéro ces terres nous ont enfin bouché le
faire mais fameux trou de la sécu il
restera à rembourser la dette et la
dette va prendre plus de temps ce sera
jusqu'en 2024
jean-francis alors on va parler
maintenant du scandale sanitaire des
salmonelles dans le lait infantile bien
sûr lactalis au sénat récemment le
directeur général de l'alimentation
patrick deleau mon avait indiqué que des
contrôles positifs ne lui avait pas été
signalé on écoute ce qui est dommage
c'est que dans la mesure où
sam la plupart des cas c'est un nouveau
des salmonelles à aegon a au delà du
fait que sap a été transmis ce qui est
dommage c'est qu'il y ait pas eu
finalement un questionnement au niveau
de l'entreprise
je suis très directs sur le fait que
c'était quand même étonnant de retrouver
une salle moderne à aegon a à plusieurs
reprises au fil des années alors qu'on
avait trouvé en 2005 pour être sûr de
bien comprendre ça veut dire que pendant
toutes ces années il y a eu des
autocontrôles d'environnement
quelques-uns positif
donc on sait reconnaître une salmonelle
à la salmonelle qui ne vous ont pas été
transmises ce sens vous ouvrez des
grands yeux barrés bon on parle de
sécurité alimentaire de produits pour
des nouveau-nés donc c'est le fabricant
des iphone directement la responsabilité
du fabricant qui est responsable de ses
autocontrôles face à la direction
générale de l'alimentation
voilà le mystère la santé quelque part à
un rôle très en amont il a un rôle d'
alerte il a repéré les huit cas groupés
de salmonella ans le 30 novembre et le
1er décembre
nous faisions un arrêté pour le retrait
des lots donc en moins c'est effectif
c'est la totale responsabilité des des
distributeurs et des formations et des
pharmaciens est d'ailleurs l'ordre des
pharmaciens a prévu d'être extrêmement
sévère sur les pharmaciens qui n'ont pas
fait alors qu'ils n'ont pas joué leur
rôle comme ce que vous qualifiez ce type
de comportement jeudi
géant laitier alors allez-y parlé avec
toute franchise non parce que je peux
être rapidement assez violent jeu
je ne comprends pas on est on est si
réellement des contrôles des autos tests
ont été positifs et n'ont pas été
transmis je pense qu'une enquête est en
cours je ne vais pas me mêler d'une
enquête judiciaire en cours
mais ce qu'il faut renforcer peut-être
la législation le devoir de signaler on
peut dire un retour d'expérience harry
faire peut-être pour mieux cibler les
contrôles
c'est peut-être la question que doivent
se poser la direction de la répression
des fraudes dgccrf et la dgr elle de
l'alimentation qui sont en charge des
contrôles des industriels de
l'alimentaire de peut-être ciblé parce
que il s'agissait quand même d'une usine
qui avait déjà eu des cas de salmonelle
en 2005 il aurait peut-être fallu être
plus attentifs ou augmenter les
contrôles mais d'un autre côté si les
auto contrôles étaient positifs et n'ont
pas été transmis ces de l'entière
responsabilité de l'année ces gens là
russe vous êtes ministre de la santé
vous est aussi ministre des solidarités
est ce que vous vous sentez totalement
solidaire de votre collègue gérard
collomb ministre de l'intérieur sur son
projet de loi asile immigration qui est
présenté mercredi
qui sème le trouble dans le monde la
majorité parce qu'il est jugé beaucoup
trop beaucoup trop dur
d'abord nous n'avons pas encore eu ce
cette présentation en conseil des
ministres et donc il sera présenté
mercredi
moi je suis complètement en phase avec
la logique
la logique de ce plan c'est de dire que
tout le monde n'a pas vocation à rester
sur le territoire en particulier
l'immigration économique elle est
importante et que par contre face à
l'immigration
subi de personnes qui fuient leur pays
pour des raisons de guerre ou par
exemple des femmes qui fuient l'excision
pour leur petite fille sont des choses
qui arrivent
nous devons accueillir nous devons faire
respecter le droit d'asile et ce droit
d'asile doit être plus précoce plus
protecteurs aujourd'hui on traite
absolument tous les deux la même façon
accélérée en fait les dispositifs qui
permettent de reconnaître à quelqu'un le
droit d'asile si il y à le faire le
ministre
pardon c'est ce que veut faire le
ministre dit c'est ce que vous allez
raccourcir les 18 mois
est ce que m plus une intégration plus
près qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de
faire plus vite ils ont pas enfin il
manque de moyens il manque de moyens
humains et non de moyens financiers il
faudra évidemment que les moyens soient
lui suivent évidemment moi j'ai dans mon
champ d'attribution les mineurs
non-accompagnés avec madame belloubet et
avec monsieur collomb et je suis par
exemple très vigilant parce que les
départements soient mieux accompagnés
ils compris financièrement et c'est ce
que nous avons mis en place dès cette
année pour pouvoir accueillir les
mineurs dans nos campagnes et qui sont
en nombre important
en tant que ministre des solidarités
vous avez aussi l'annoncé en un plan de
lutte contre la pauvreté axée sur les
enfants et sur les jeunes en mars
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelles
sont les pistes qui vont être retenues
pour ce plan alors c'est trop tôt pour
dire les pistes peut-être parler partir
du constat aujourd'hui la le visage de
la pauvreté a changé dans notre pays
il touche majoritairement les jeunes les
familles monoparentales avec enfants et
nous avons trois millions d'enfants
aujourd'hui qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
or toutes les études montrent que ces
pauvres d'aujourd'hui seront les pauvres
de demain car notre système globalement
d'éducation d'accompagnement ne permet
pas de sortir ces enfants et ces jeunes
de la pauvreté et donc ils sont assignés
à résidence donc le plan vise à lutter
contre justement cette discrimination
des l'enfant de la petite enfance pour
donner de l'espoir et des perspectives à
cette jeunesse donc rendez vous dans
quelques semaines vous avez encore le
temps ce de vous plonger dans les revues
scientifiques qui parle d'hématologie
madame la ministre
parce que c'est un secteur très
important qui va permettre demain de
détecter précocement on le sait dès que
tu es cancer vous avez le temps de
rester au top niveau de cette spécialité
qui fut la vaunage je n'en peu frustré
car les revues médicales
voilà s'amoncellent dans mon dos
derrière moi et je l'écrasé par les
parapheurs un peu écrasée par les
parfums fonctions la charge
c'est un regret au tous les cas là où
vous êtes alors j'y reviendrai peut-être
reviendrait peut-être merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
merci messieurs la semaine prochaine
bien nous serons au salon de
l'agriculture et nous recevrons votre
collègue stéphane travert bonsoir à tout
ça très vite
[Musique]